the whaling commission it's so
interesting how they can go out and they
can find countries in the Caribbean all
total countries all over the world
they're basically what countries they
can buy so how to explain to me how that
works how that whole process works and
how that benefits them well do it for
many this is just one so there's the
International Whaling Commission that
regulates whaling Japan has left that
now they're not part of it they just
left two years ago because they're like
we're just going to resume we're like on
our own and not be part of this and so
and so what you haven't been allowed to
whale for years and so what Japan did
there's a loophole that you can do some
whaling for scientific research so they
just painted on the side of all their
whaling ships a big cross and wrote
scientific research and like when people
would fly over to monitor they'll hold
up Stein's while they're chopping the
whale up saying we are testing tissue
samples you know but then the next week
and the grocery stores that same way all
he's everywhere he's in every grocery
store and so what Japan would do is to
try to control the whaling commission to
make these new polls is they'll go to
countries that are not members of the
whaling commission like small poor
Caribbean countries or South Pacific
countries and they'll build something
for them you know we'll we'll build you
a new runway we'll build you a new road
we'll build you a fisheries building
that was the famous one in the Caribbean
name it we'll build you a ten million
dollar like you know half these islands
have no building that cost ten million
dollars I'm gonna put you guys at ten
million dollar building to house your
fisheries offices well they didn't need
a fisheries office before that and they
didn't need one after so a year later
the building's empty there's chickens
running through it they've got this they
call them white elephants it's like this
project well then just a year later
there's weeds growing through it and
like and but but for that you have to
join the International Whaling
Commission and you vote how we vote and
we'll pay every year when the meeting
you know Jen it's like whenever you're
when there's a meeting will pay for your
delegation to fly first-class through
the meeting and you know we'll give you
whatever you
very massages and staying and I said
tell and so it's a win for them Wow I
mean you think about think about Taiji
the only people benefiting out of it are
basically the 40 guys that are involved
the guys that run the boats their hands
up the guys work on the boats and the
guys that work in the slaughterhouse
they're the only ones profiting no one
else in the village is profiting it's
these 40 guys their little fishery they
have a dolphin hunting Union and that
Union is the only one profiting Japan
allowed this to go on and these 40 guys
are the only ones benefiting the towns
are benefiting the cove probably did
billions of dollars of damage to Japan's
economy there are people that will never
travel to Japan again that will never
buy a Japanese car that will never buy
Japanese products ever again because of
what they saw in the cove it was in tens
of thousands of newspaper articles I
mean it was that the worst PR campaign
ever for them and they allowed it to go
on and back up these 40 guys doing what
they do it's just so bizarre
[Laughter]